desafiando a los militares en las calles
luego de una nueva sangrienta jornada de
represión militar contra los
manifestantes antigolpistas en mianmar
este sábado se elevó a más de 80 el
número de personas asesinadas en la
localidad de vago los ataques con
explosivos sin munición real de las
fuerzas de seguridad mientras que un
tribunal de justicia marcial condenó a
la pena capital a 19 personas acusadas
del asesinato de un soldado en la
primera sentencia impuesta por la junta
militar desde el golpe de estado 19
personas han sido condenadas a muerte
mianmar por matar a un asociado de un
capitán del ejército dijo la estación de
televisión mía igualdad y propiedad del
ejército dijo que 17 de las personas
fueron sentenciadas en rebeldía más al
sur en el estado de sant una alianza de
grupos étnico rebeldes atacó una
estación de policía matando a unos diez
uniformados a finales de marzo las
guerrillas étnicas bajo la alianza de
las tres hermandades lanzaron un
ultimátum al tatmadaw por la brutal
represión contra las protestas pacíficas
el reciente asalto es el mayor signo de
que el país está adentrándose en una
guerra civil una alianza de grupos
étnicos armados en mianmar que había
amenazado con tomar medidas por la
de la junta contra las protestas
antigolpistas atacó y una estación de
policía en el estado de shan y al menos
diez agentes murieron dijeron medios
nacionales casi 700 personas han muerto
en los últimos dos meses desde que la
junta militar derrocó al gobierno civil
de anza en su xxxiii mediante un golpe
militar a medida que la violencia
continúa intensificándose en todo mi
alma